i want to talk to people that have just
stood right there
on the welcome mat of heaven
or hell
and um
i want to get close to something
on this show close to something real um
and we're gonna talk today to one we got
a man i'll uh i'll show a clip from the
past from um when he first called into
the show
our boy dalton trained victim
and uh i'm looking forward uh to talking
to this man
what's going on uh my name is dalton
i've been listening to the show off and
on for a while now if you
mentioned some about your uncle or i
forget who got hit by a train
i can relate because uh when i was in
high school it was probably like
10 years ago i was actually hit by a
train
on the way to school i was walking to
school
and
i lived
and uh
yeah i don't know if you want me to i
can send you damn send me what a dog
you gonna send me some arms son i'm just
joking man
wow
on the line there dalton can you hear me
i can hear you brother what's up baby
there he is
man you're a mirror you're a miracle
brother
hey living a miracle wow baby that
little box car bad boy son that rail
baby
okay hey yes man
dude i feel uplifted even just seeing
you man uh thanks for joining us for a
little bit today
thanks for having me
yeah man so you know you've had a really
unique experience that other people
haven't had you've been hit by a train
and it just doesn't happen to folks uh
can you take us through some of that
yeah no problem so when i was in uh it
was in high school i was in high school
about 10 years ago
and uh
when i would walk to school there was a
set of train tracks that every kid would
have to cross to get to school oh yeah
then risk sticks baby that's what those
are son gang baby day
okay sorry for interrupting you go on
it's high school you're out there you're
walking to school
yeah no problem um yeah so in my mind
i've never seen a
train go by on these train tracks it
like very seldomly does a train go by on
these train tracks
and it was right after christmas and i
got a big set of headphones for
christmas
yeah and uh i was walking to school and
i would know when to look up um like
it's like across the street look both
ways
but this set of trains i'm not i'm
saying you know it's
mostly my fault that this happened i'm
not blaming anybody for this but i was
looking down
with headphones on
and the train was going very slow
and when i uh think about it
if there was a camera on the situation
what had to have happened was the trains
going like this
and i'm walking like this
and perfect timing i step on the track
train runs over my foot
hits me in the head
it was only two carts long so it wasn't
a long train but oh really i went
underneath
yeah
and then i popped back out and then i
woke up
and then
somebody seen the whole situation
somebody had the flag the train down
wow they didn't even stop what was going
on
now were you um what what song were you
listening to
i was i was listening to aussie
revelation mother earth
dang
so yeah that's kind of heavy metal
yes heavy metal on the heavy metal yeah
bro that's really wow i mean that's
almost like your ears are asking for it
they wanted that you know they wanted
the heart they wanted some real
percussion going on they wanted that
heavy percussion section um were you
conscious after you come out the bottom
of it
i woke up after like just beside the
tracks i woke up i spit up blood
i lifted up my leg and my leg was like
completely
like just limp like everything was
shattered in there and it was just
completely limp like a tongue almost huh
basically yeah a long tongue
and so um did it knock your shoes off or
anything
see this is the weird part yeah it
knocked my shoes off and the shoes were
completely fine so
i kept wearing those
you kept wearing them
well like after i go to the hospital you
know a good pair of shoes
i mean i i think i'd get i'd feel like
i'd burn everything but i like your
attitude you're just gonna go right back
in there and that's one thing that i
really did admire about you man was
some of your attitude i remember
whenever you called in you said
that you'd been hit by a train and some
of the positive effects that had come
out of that
and that if you if you could do it again
that you would do it again you'd run it
back
absolutely um i honestly think that
if somebody could go through a
near-death experience and survive
obviously
very healing process like it's almost
like god you know sat me down and said
you got to take this more seriously you
know like
i you know try and live
like you know i hope for tomorrow but
you never know
yeah it's like god's saying i choo choo
choose you dog you know what i'm saying
absolutely
now what are some things that kind of
happened to you like uh what are some of
the like um uplifting thoughts and
attitudes what what positives kind of
happened inside of you after that like
what adjusted if anything did
well
i kind of felt like before that
like
i was in high school and i was a kid
before that i was kind of like on
autopilot
and you know i would just you know i
didn't know who i was and
i was just kind of on autopilot in life
and after that experience
you know it really
showed me that
you know i had to come into my own
character and showed me that life is
important you know like
um
made me it's a part of who i am and it
made me who i am i wouldn't change it at
all i don't know where i'd be if that
wouldn't happen
if that didn't happen
wow that's really it's just such a
fascinating take on it man because i
think to be honest there's a lot of
folks out there that that are that would
like to i think get hit by a train but
aren't willing to put in the time you
know aren't willing to really
you know put their nuts on the you know
in the basket or whatever you know the
ten thousand hours
yeah yeah they're not really yeah
they're not willing to really show up
and do the work um did it help you in
any sense with the ladies or anything
that was there any kind of did it have
an effect on people other people
you know it is kind of a weird situ it
has been a weird situation i am that guy
that got hit by a train hell yeah i walk
into the bar oh you're that guy that got
hit by a train i'm like yeah you know it
happens
but uh
on the ladies side you know like people
are interested or like it's interesting
but you know like
i don't know it hasn't uh i haven't
gotten any more or any less ladies
because of it i'd like to think because
my character
yeah well it's funny i feel like you and
i almost look the same i feel like you
and me are some somewhat versions of
each other in some sense man um now did
it hit your penis or anything did any of
your body get mangled like that did your
wiener get hit out or whatever no uh
fortunately not uh it basically just my
foot you want to see it
oh yeah
yeah yeah i think i do
so this this freaks the kids out when i
show them but yeah but [__] the kids man
whoa boy damn you got that eternal peace
sign son
[Laughter]
so yeah i lost three toes
and
this is a skin graft on top
from my leg
like from uh my thigh
and the weird part is his hair grows on
this now
because it's from my leg oh i'm like do
i shave my foot or
[Laughter]
hell yeah grow a little soul patch on
there s-s-o-l-e
dude that's phenomenal man i i i love
your attitude um
did it did it adjust the way that you
interact with people afterwards did it
have any effect on that i could really
see that happening
well
like i said people
you know i am branded with this
situation like you know everybody knows
it's like and i understand
how crazy it is for somebody to see
somebody it's like oh they got hit by a
train
but uh the way i act towards people
is i'm always talking about you know
life and god and this and that and you
know sometimes people get uh weirded out
but
you know this is this is the game of
life you know
yeah important it is important do you
feel like god was reaching out to you
absolutely
knocked me off my horse and said you
need to take this game of life seriously
wow wow that's interesting do you feel
like it made you more religious it
really really just you know tied your
shoelaces directly to the lord's
you know uh long hair
absolutely um
i don't believe in
i believe all gods are real
you know whatever you believe is real
and you know that experience made me
really feel like you know there there is
an architect there is something out
there
you know
planning things putting tracks in front
of things you know amen baby all the
lord you know what i'm saying boy let's
get it dude
wow man well dude it's just you know i
love your attitude man getting to see
you i've been wanting to for a while
i've just been kind of like
kind of getting well my just taking care
of myself and um been having a lot of
guests on but i really wanted to connect
back with you man uh you've been on my
mind uh just because your attitude about
saying hey man
run it back if i can have an experience
that brings me that close to realizing
the value of my existence
that i'm willing to almost do that that
there's that there must be such a value
in that huh i mean it must feel really
because you you can't just get that you
can't just create that
absolutely like i would equate it to
like maybe you know a psychedelic
experience or like it really make it
makes me at least like i don't know
anybody else in their psyche how they
would react to it but for me it makes me
feel the weight of every day
amen and that you know this is the one
shot we only get one shot one
opportunity this is it dude mom
spaghetti son i feel you bro
well look man i'll i'd love to check in
with you again man we'll send you some
merch and stuff like that and just uh
get you dripped out we don't have any
dope ass socks for you but uh
you know we'll see what we can do man
and just thanks for being alive man um
do you accredit anything inside of you
that you feel like uh
do you feel like you were the guy that
was supposed to get hit by a train if
people would have said before who's
supposed to get hit by a train
you think people would have picked you
or you think you just really
you know just caught that lucky uh
[__] long bus you know
i honestly think it was supposed to be
me man like my
my mental strength like i believe that
you know i'm mentally strong not like
i'm not trying to like boast or anything
but you know this is your life look dude
you got hit by the train you you guys
your time to tell us
i just i don't know if the average
person would be able to handle this and
walk away
from it you know normal i remember when
they wheeled me because i was in a
wheelchair they wheeled me into the
psych ward
and i'm just like they're trying they're
trying to see if i'm like mentally this
that or whatever yeah and i'm like like
i'm not having this like you know
i was it was a weird experience but yeah
it didn't affect me
funny thing is is when i'm watching
movies with my friends and there's like
somebody gets hit by a train
in the movie
everybody looks to me
and i'm like i'm like what guys come on
it's only true it's only a train i beat
that train yeah it's one train baby yeah
you [__] won i've never come back
with something bigger you know like yeah
that's what i'm saying dude i want to
see a ufo [__] land on your back son
i'm ready for a [__] blimp to hit you
dog i'm afraid to take you to the super
bowl
led zeppelin yeah bro i think anything's
ready bro you'll catch a missile in your
mouth son you could do whatever you want
absolutely
it did make me think of this just a
second ago you were talking about uh
what did you say just a second ago
before you were talking about your first
psych ward they wheeled me into the
psych ward they tried to make you crazy
yes wow they tried to think you was like
[__] or whatever because you've been
hit by a train
want to hear something else crazy too
yeah this was at the beginning of the
whole opiate epidemic right
this nurse came into the doctors or into
the hospital and she's like
we're gonna prescribe you oxycontin
and i was like
no no i smoke marijuana for my pain
and then she i'll never forget this till
the day i die she's like
oxycontin is healthier than marijuana
wow and i was just like can i get a new
nurse this is this woman is insane like
you know this is yeah can i get this
[__] a train somebody ordered this
[__] a train bro
because that since it's unbelievable
that someone that any human would think
that
absolutely it was insane they were truly
selling it like
it blew my mind
yeah wow
man well it's it's funny you die i mean
that that's a [__] that's a dirtier
train to dodge right there man you died
wow
well dude man i i love your attitude man
i'd love it if we could check in with
you every now and then and just kind of
see what's going on um where do you live
at sure
um i live in uh like around niagara
falls canada so like right at the border
basically
that's nice it's nice up there
yeah it's nice uh
niagara falls one of the seven
wonders of the world i'm i've seen it so
many times that it's just normal to me
but can you drink off it or you can't
get that close to it
i didn't do a drink can you drink off of
it if you get close to it or can you
have to stay far back yeah
you can taste it on your lips definitely
but you couldn't you couldn't get a full
sip but you get a half sip um that's
fair i guess
um do you any of your senses heightened
after getting hit by that training
anything do you do you feel like you
have any
unique i don't want to say powers but
that's what people are going to say
powers okay do you have any unique sense
or any sense any heightened senses or
slash powers
absolutely like i was saying like um
i feel the weight of every day
a lot more like uh i was reading this
book and there was soldier uh it was
about soldiers in world war ii
and
uh they were at the point where they
knew they were the situation where they
knew they were gonna die there was no if
ands or buts
they know they're gonna die
and because of that
every moment is sweeter the next your
next meal means everything your next
kiss means everything in the world
so and people like they these soldiers
almost liked that
feeling of you could die at any moment
and i don't i don't claim to be like
you know like
like a red dot on my head like you know
i'm gonna die in this moment but i sort
of feel like i you know feel the weight
of life a lot more you know
yeah yeah like there's just uh
like it's gotta everything has a lot
stronger taste to it every every
moment
absolutely wow
yeah man you're out there baby that
little rail monkey dalton
run it back two trains baby look man
i'm proud of you dude and i'm glad to
meet you
glad to meet you too theo you know
you're an inspiration to all of us
creatives
especially because you're a comedian and
you know you make
you
you're not some glossy
thing where you
you're a real person and you
show us all that we can make it being us
you know we don't have to be this uh
bigger than life thing we could be us
well thanks man i appreciate that yeah
i'm just trying yeah i'm just
it's hard to be
anybody you know it's hard to be yeah
it's hard to be it's a real challenge it
feels like sometimes and um
that's nice you to say man i appreciate
it uh
and yeah i think
you do the same man you make me feel
like hey it's okay if i only got
you know um
you know
if i'm if i'm missing toes or i'm
growing a [__] uh sideburn on my
[__] foot baby let's go you know what
i'm saying
gotta get that manscaped yeah
i don't know if they make anything to
cover that bro they're [__] missing
out you should sue them
[Laughter]
thank you bro it's nice to make your
acquaintance and um when we get up there
to his show man we'll have to have you
come out and uh so you and i can get to
meet in person man
absolutely i've been waiting for you to
come to canada man
yeah we'll get up there soon my tour
manager is from ontario london ontario
okay yeah that's i've been there that's
close
so um he'll get me up in that area soon
man but uh but yeah we'll do something
nice then we'll send you one of these
bobble heads dude and get you out there
and get you some uh some items or
something that you want and uh just
thank you bro thank you for sharing
yourself with us and um
[__] yeah dude if somebody get hit by a
train and just keep on just trucking
then i can do that today you know so
thank you dog
love you theo love you man one love amen
baby you're a miracle thanks dalton
thank you
a miracle right there
a miracle
and we got to listen to them
and we got to learn from them
man i'm grateful for that today
it's a real perspective switch you know
it's a real perspective switch
it makes my problem i mean
my problems seem like micro machines
right there
when you got a fella that's just damn
that's just getting trained out
man
grateful to be alive today um grateful
to exist on this planet
um
working on staying in gratitude myself
you know uh still battling some anger
here and there and um
some
i don't know if it's ego or just
you know thinking things are supposed to
be a certain way
expectation you know i'd love to not
approach the day with a lot of
expectation
i'd love to just
sit there and watch god paint
you know
but usually i want to get up and i want
to open up this color in this color and
you know i'll see what he does i'm only
giving him four colors you know
i'm giving him this brush i want the
white brown
instead of just sitting back and saying
all right
let me see what magic
this big dog
is going to do with the canvas of my
life you know
what's he gonna paint what's he gonna
put out there
and just not to look for the end product
but to enjoy the uh
the colors along the
way hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one